vamos a hablar ahora de baloncesto de la
polémica que hay en la nba por esta
estrella que se niega a vacunarse contra
el kobe 19 ya hemos hablado de él pero
diga quienes hablamos de khadr y en base
de los brooklyn nets y un campeón de un
título de la nba
irven se niega a vacunarse contra el
cometa 19 argumentando que está haciendo
lo que es mejor para él este domingo su
equipo debutó en casa en el barclays
center de brooklyn en la ciudad nueva
york y a las afueras del estadio vimos a
una multitud que se manifestó en favor
de irving pidiendo que lo dejen jugar lo
que pasa con irvine es que las leyes de
la gran manzana obligan a los
deportistas profesionales a estar
vacunados si quieren jugar en la ciudad
y desde los brooklyn nets dicen que no
van a contar con él hasta que esté
disponible al completo y por eso irving
tampoco juega en los partidos de
visitante los nets por cierto sufrieron
anoche su segunda derrota en tres
partidos el respecto habló kevin durant
otra de sus estrellas
y claramente queremos que caiga bien
esté ahí en la cancha y él es una gran
parte de lo que hacemos
pero eso no va a pasar ahora así que
tendremos que resolverlo pero no vamos a
perder la confianza mientras jugamos con
la esperanza de que irving venga y nos
salve en el partido